hey everybody i'm back for the second
stream of the day we are now standing by
for the resumption of donald trump's
coronavirus press briefings
um this is this is a desperate trump
this is a trump who knows his back is
against the wall even though he says all
the polls are fake
he knows he's losing and this is one of
the ideas that he has
along with sending paramilitaries to
american cities
to repress protests this is one of the
ideas he has
about how he might be able to
recover the polling support that he has
lost
over the last three months so i don't
know what to expect
other than we've been told dr fausci
said an hour ago he wasn't invited
so the question of you know if it's a
coronavirus press briefing i want to
hear from doctors and ideally not dr
burks because she's basically shown
herself to be untrustworthy
it's not clear that we're even going to
have doctors here so
my suspicion is that this is a
propaganda event in total obviously to
some degree they are
it may only be a propaganda event
um and we are standing by looking at
three different streams to see if and
when
um these go live scheduled for 5 p.m and
hopefully they will sort of be on time i
mean they these people are notoriously
late
but we will a very very soon see
thanks to everybody who's back for the
second stream of the day some of you
joined me earlier for kaylee mckennany's
press briefing she's the white house
press secretary
and there is a third stream scheduled
for later which will not be a serious
stream
it will just be um women's chess player
alexandra botez will be coaching me for
my upcoming
uh pog champs to participation and
that'll be later and i look forward to
folks
joining me for that as well that may be
twitch only
um i haven't met yet made a call about
that
um but you'll you'll know that's for
sure
um super chats are already coming in and
many of them are about the tragic loss
of michael brooks we learned yesterday
that fellow progressive host michael
brooks had suddenly passed away
my same age michael brooks and it's been
uh it's just been a shock the last 24
hours and i
already recorded a you know piece about
this on my podcast which will publish to
youtube
in about 40 minutes so i won't say too
too much about it but i do want to
mention some of the things that have
been said
john howell said a standard of vision is
established
2020 rest in power michael brooks
and captain crunch says rest in power
michael brooks
never forgotten i see some people in the
chat talking about the great
tribute that majority the majority
report did today
uh for michael brooks i did watch most
of it and it was really great it was so
great to hear from
i mean i couldn't possibly name
everybody so i don't i'm not going to
try
but certainly my friend anna casparian
commented beautifully um
and a lot of other people i see people
in the chat asking about
the shot at me that happened yeah i saw
that you know
i it that i actually felt hurt by that
so during this tribute
um matt binder who i understand
i met him once or twice when i would go
to sam's studio when i lived in new york
i understand he was more the technical
producer at the time
in the middle of talking about how they
met michael and as many of you know i
i knew michael in western massachusetts
and introduced him to sam when i found
out michael was looking for
opportunities
um binder sort of said like oh yeah you
know we were
it was like he came from the pacman show
he can't be that great
or can't be that smart but we gave him a
shot anyway and then again sort of
implied like
that the dave my i guess he doesn't like
my show which is totally fine but it
felt
you know my message on the podcast today
about michael brooks is
many of us on the left don't have the
exact same politics
but we should this should be a reminder
to sort of come together and realize we
don't want to miss the forest for the
trees
etc etc and really you know
a sense of togetherness so to speak and
so it was particularly hurtful i mean i
admit i i found it really hurtful when
in the middle you know of this great
tribute matt binder sort of says
he doesn't belong on the pacman show
he's too smart for the you know
he's smart this is the show for him not
the pacman show i was hurt by it and
i don't want to make it about me so i i
haven't you know like
i'm not going to send a tweet about it
or anything like that but um
i i was hurt by it if i'm totally
totally honest with you for sure
um other super chats coming in c
says i know your v you visited london
but where else have you visited in
england and where would you like to
visit i've only i've been to london
and i've been to oxford and um
i would love to i would love to get to
know more of uh of england for sure
donna williams says i appreciate your
commentary you make these live fests
more tolerable i appreciate your support
donna williams says any more thoughts on
a bingo card for kaylee yeah i may do it
you know i don't want to overdo stuff
and if it's all bingo bingo bingo bingo
card for trump and this and that
i want people wanting more the fact that
people ask for the bingo card
is a good sign right because that means
i'm not doing too much of it where
where it gets boring thank you to margot
cabot
for subscribing on twitch as well as
sabine brenda for subscribing with prime
new john has gifted a subscription
ranyan has subscribed on twitch
so has toady capote for seven months
and henna baked ham as well as
ribeye roque have subscribed
which i appreciate very very much this
is scheduled for 5 p.m
eastern the top of the hour we are now
live in the room here
and we will we will stay on this shot um
to see
when this starts and hopefully it will
be sooner than
later um other super chats
zach bushman says what's your secret for
listening to trump i have to mute him
whenever
he talks because i feel my brain cells
dying just desensitization i would say
that's really it um captain crunch has
subscribed on youtube
whoa lost some things there hold on
breaker19 says david if you pause the
stream instead of mute
during your interjections everybody will
be happy so we don't miss anything i've
tried that people
aren't happy when i do that
unfortunately
um david belski says trump should bring
the president of finland to these press
briefings i would welcome
any actual leader at these press
briefings any leader
i would take any leader at all uh junie
mcgraw
says hey dp people like you michael
brooke sam cedar kyle kolinsky really
evolved my political views after 2016.
michael brook's death reminded me how
ephemeral life is take care of yourself
rest in peace michael brooks well said
daniel krieger says don't take matt
binder personally dave we love you too
okay
thank you adam kennedy says trump wants
coronavirus to rage
and chaos in the streets so he can
declare martial law and cancel the
election
i have a similar take that's not quite
so hyperbolic and i'm going to lay it
out on tomorrow's podcast
but you're not crazy in the vein of what
you're thinking
charlie says from the standpoint of
money twenty dollars is merely a slice
thanks for your awesome streams
smash that like button please yeah if
you're watching on youtube
i we need that like button destroyed
absolutely destroyed
james ramos says here in switzerland we
have like 50 cases a day many things are
open the u.s looks like a dystopian
movie
it is indeed one it is indeed
jacob ratner says thoughts on small
government people defending secret
police
hypocrites i mean listen um
at this point i don't even know if it's
worth spending a lot of time
ex like exposing that hypocrisy because
one side just doesn't care about
hypocrisy so it's like why
we care about it but we're already not
voting for these clowns what's the point
of continuing to expose
hypocrisy that only we care about we're
already not voting for them and they
certainly don't seem to care
jonathan says david how do you feel
about susan rice as a potential vp pick
for biden
i haven't weighed in because i don't
know enough about her to really say
like i'm very familiar with elizabeth
warren's politics very familiar with
kamala harris's and some others
um i so i'm not well positioned to say
people in twitch are asking who i'm
voting for
if you mean in the presidential election
who do you think
sweet baby bladefoot says similar to
michael brooks i appreciate your lens of
compassion that you bring to the issues
we care about stay well for us thank you
i appreciate that
eskiel tester says trump sends troops to
prep for martial law i see a lot of
people with that idea
alex endicott says david thank you for
always taking it to the front door of
the conservatives and never giving them
an inch you do
more than many of your peers i
appreciate that
thanks to ae7c
for subscribing with twitch prime
at twitch.tv
david pakman as we see folks come in i
believe this is kristin welker
from nbc getting ready to do
looks like a brief live appearance
uh angela mitchell says do you think
ginsberg will retire once powers change
hands republicans are chomping at the
bit to fill another skoda seat
i believe so i mean listen i i don't
want to be dark in any way but i believe
that
ruth bader ginsburg is trying to do what
she can
to stick it out on the court until
hopefully joe biden gets to pick her
replacement that's my
uh that's my belief robert mifflin
says you say massachusetts did well but
fourth worst
death per capita yes so there's two
phases with coronavirus and i've
explained this before
the early hot spots when we had no idea
what we needed to do
it was a new situation the early hot
spots were based on who has the most
direct flights
to the affected areas numerous direct
flights to china from boston's logan
airport new york has
two major airports newark and uh jfk
with a lot of those flights san
francisco la another example chicago
which is why you see illinois
early on the early hot spots were a
result not of policy but
of of essentially being very well
connected to asia and direct flights to
europe
once we understood what we need to do it
takes months
for the curves to adjust because of the
process but now what you are seeing
in terms of case growth rates are
policy related statistics and so
you have to sort of divide coronavirus
into
two stages now that we understand what
works masks work for example
not gathering indoors etc uh now you're
seeing
a very different situation where it is
california and red states
that are really the places the hot spots
with problems right now
and if that analysis is interesting to
you
i have um a bunch of of clips about that
on my youtube channel the blue noble
says i have a special plant gift for you
on instagram the fair forager
will be giving away dragon fruit
cuttings yours will be dark star
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't know nikolai furiska says love
your show keep bringing the truth
andreas peterson says oh no not another
emergency rally yeah well this one's an
emergency
trump's polling is really the emergency
that's what the that's what they mean by
emergency here
let me say thank you to david sample
david sample is new member number one
today
at joinpackman.com um i have
been limiting the membership pitches to
just
60 seconds on recent streams too much
success
it seems like the less i mention it the
better we do
so i'll do that brief mention now we are
a program
mostly supported by viewers our three
streams today and the hour podcast and
the youtube clips all of that stuff is
mostly funded
by just like nice normal people who go
to joinpakman.com
and grab a membership and we've had a
lot of people do to coronavirus have to
bail on memberships not because they
want to but because they have to
and we want to keep doing the show for
everybody even for the folks that have
had to cancel memberships because
i understand what's going on so if
you're in the boat of someone
who has a couple bucks a month head over
to joinpakman.com
we have an even better coupon code than
this 2020 now is a
very powerful coupon code but this is an
unpublished coupon code i'm about to
give
you july surprise okay
it's all one word it's all lower case
that's the little letters
and no spaces july surprise um
we're talking about you know really
small amounts of money that support
everything we do
uh you know we do we we try to take care
of our employees health insurance i'm
looking into retirement plans and all of
this stuff because i want to i want to
be part of the solution and not the
problem
um so folks signing up at
joinedpakman.com allow us to do that
and i will do my best to thank every
single one of you that signs up during
this stream
time permitting as i like to say as uh
some final
looks like hair and makeup touches are
being uh established here
elements of hair and makeup happening
right before our eyes i will thank
everybody who uh who i can
danny thompson says oh where did danny
thompson's matches go david
here is how smart i think you are and
how much i appreciate you i am a member
of your show
three different paid memberships in fact
i do not even subscribe to majority
report in youtube for free oh my god
danny well you could do feel
i won't feel uh betrayed if you
subscribe to majority report i think
that that's fine i think it's a
beautiful thing
huge thank you to not vargex 9
for gifting 20 subscriptions on twitch
20 and darth bane has gifted
10 more and then not vargas 9
gifted another 20 coming out of nowhere
i mean just coming completely out of
nowhere and
um i think
that and oh and not varg x9 also
subscribed themselves so an unbelievable
unbelievable day
um of winning and progressivism i guess
is uh
the way i would say it there is a third
stream scheduled for tonight it will be
a chess coaching
stream where alexandra botez will be
coaching me
and it was scheduled originally for six
but i wanted to make sure to
six eastern i wanted to make sure to
cover this
so it's been pushed back i think she
said she'll be streaming for for several
hours
so i'm gonna ping her when it's time to
go and that'll be
that'll be a little bit later jake v
x1k says do you think trump will unveil
clorox
chewables today yeah that that may be
that may be
if you are just joining us donald trump
resuming a coronavirus press briefings
out of desperation um apparently there
will not be doctors joining him on stage
or at least not dr anthony fauci
so i'm expecting a complete and total
[ __ ] show
um let's see captain crunch says the
only way to truly
honor michael brooks is to all come
together
and defeat trump in november and for the
sake of humanity i agree very powerfully
with that
green lover says hey brother we loves
you keep on keeping on uk fan club here
love the uk fans megan curran says lol
at the white house for thinking a
reporter called
magga nanny a lying [ __ ] today it's
projection on their part
you know in one video clip someone
played for me i did hear it but i
couldn't tell whether
it had been added after the fact i just
really couldn't tell uh it was
it was bizarre i want to say thank you
to the bad wolf for subscribing on
twitch thanks to beef
goggles for the sub the legend of wheat
bread has subscribed
mike and obi has also subscribed
if you are just joining us you have not
missed anything trump is four minutes
late already
and we expect him to be somewhere
between four and a hundred minutes late
that's usually the range in which he
operates
certainly if you are just joining on
youtube uh oh boy now my uh my phone is
blowing up that's that's rude of me i
apologize
i should silence my phone for streams
and usually i do if you're just joining
on youtube
make sure to hit that like and subscribe
button we are
so close to having 888 888 subscribers
oh my god no we just passed it we just
literally got 100 subscribers in like 30
seconds when
we passed i was hoping to take a
screenshot of 88888
and we just blew past it unbelievable
unbelievable
don't unsubscribe though that's not what
i'm implying
not at all what i'm implying okay cookie
says finally got a sub to your website
glad to find you love you david you are
inspiring
me to be more active in politics
beautiful thing
i hope to do that i hope to do that
banana nutcrunch
says did you hear about asheville north
carolina voting to give its black
citizens reparations i did not
we'll look into it uh oh by the way a
brief technical update
as many of you know maybe people find
this interesting maybe people don't
this electro voice re20 microphone this
thing right here
you you under you guys can hear this
right this microphone has been with me
essentially for 10 years at this point
in time
and um i've mentioned
recently that there's a bit of a
harshness to the audio
lately particularly since we moved into
this room that i don't
love and some viewers who are proficient
in audio matters have reached out to me
and i have made a decision to
try a new microphone and i know that
this is going to be extremely disturbing
and distracting to some people because
this microphone has been
the status quo for a decade on this
program
this same might not this model this
exact
microphone but uh i have decided to try
out the shure
sm7b um of course
uh uh joe rogan uses the sm-7b
the great samuel cedar uses the sm-7b
and i um i i got some messages
from a few different people who said
give it a shot give it a shot because
you might like the the sort of softness
that you will get from it not
low volume but rounding out some of the
harshness so
one is on route and probably monday i
will be trying it out
and we will see how people react to a
completely different microphone on the
david pakman show it could be
extremely disturbing to a lot of people
and i understand that
but i'm going to give it a shot and
other people have recommended i i really
upgrade to a neumann
um but the thing about the neumann from
what i understand
is it is so sensitive to any noise
that even my voice processing would
would be unlikely to
be able to properly get rid of
background noise like the air
conditioning or a construction site
outside
while not affecting my voice so we're
going to try the sm-7b
i agree i believe the neumann is is a
bit overkill
and that'll be for next week so
for people who care about microphones
which is only a few of you
we'll we'll be learning about that very
strongly next week
let me say thank you to some folks who
just signed up on my website this is
unbelievable
cine is new member number two susan care
is new member number three phil young is
new member number four
kelly saban is new member number five
mark
kimball is number six seven is patrick
knoll
timothy gayan gavin
is new member number eight michelle
easton
is new member number nine kelly robito
has signed up in his number 10 today
louise o'dwyer is number 11
and noah crowe is new member number 12
today i really appreciate that very very
much so
uh if you're just joining you've not
missed the stream this we are just
starting we're just starting
and um trump is 10 minutes late we're
waiting for trump right now
other super chats that are coming in
remy lebro
says i'm worried about how an emboldened
unchecked anonymous
cbp will affect my home border town
forced deportation sound like stephen
miller's fantasy
well i'll talk about what i think you're
talking about tomorrow
thanks to sm smelling fleming sorry not
smelling
oh god fleming scaffoldguard for the
youtube membership
and comrade dostoyevsky as well the dark
half
says if you were here for a pseudo rally
from a dementia riddled
old man then you found the spot that
that's mean
sand snake says what was the earlier
briefing about basically kaylee mcinanni
continuing to insist that trump is going
to rescue us from violent protesters
uh the the the nation over essentially
um white death says hi david love your
show keep it up
have you considered interviewing some
uyghur activists like
nuri turkle or irade kashgari
i would love that please email me about
that
evan field says plus or minus 10 minutes
before mango mussolini melts down i
don't i think he'll melt down when it
gets to questions
uh i and he he'll probably talk more
than 10 minutes
so i think it'll be more than 10 in that
sense nicta gamer says how many members
do you currently have
i don't have the edit that answer
actually it the number is in flux so
people are canceling and subscribing etc
etc i don't actually know the answer to
that
wade flores says hey david no question
today i wanted to say love the show keep
up the good work
thank you bae photo says will roger
stone be heavily involved with advising
trump's campaign now
how dangerous could things get i don't
know about roger stone but dangerous is
exactly the word that i used
on a clip which we just published
on youtube which is a desperate trump
is a dangerous trump okay i encourage
you to check out
that video thomas w says left is best
rest in power michael brooks well said
bob rabbit says thank you david you
change lives every day
rest in peace michael brooks let's go to
donald trump
well thank you very much and good
afternoon
today i want to provide an update on our
response to the china virus oh boy
and what my administration is doing to
get the outbreak
in the sun belt under control seems
largely in sun belt but could be
spreading
my team is also working night and day
with capitol hill to advance the next
economic
relief package we're working very hard
on it we're making a lot of progress
i also know that
both sides want to get it done we'll
call it phase four i think we're going
to get it done we'll
protect our workers our schools and our
families and protect them very strongly
as one family we mourn every precious
life that's been lost i pledge in
their honor that we will develop a
vaccine
and we will defeat the virus we're doing
very well with
vaccine development and therapeutic
development remember unrelated detriment
but i want to thank our brave doctors
and nurses
and front-line responders the job they
do is incredible and they are truly
brave
my administration will stop at nothing
to save lives and
shield the vulnerable which is so
important give me you've learned so much
about this disease
and we know who the vulnerable is this
is what's clear
people got to trump and they said if you
don't want to lose by 15 you've got to
start talking like this
and it seems like trump is acquiescing
if you look at the old system and look
at the new system i think by years
the china virus is a vicious and
dangerous by the way china virus come on
dude
about it and who it targets
we are in the process of
developing a strategy that's going to be
very very powerful we've developed as we
go along
some areas of our country are doing very
well others are doing less well
yes it will probably unfortunately
get worse before it gets better
something i don't like saying
wow things but that's the way it is
amazing that they got trump to say that
they've decided
you've got to concede it's going to get
worse because he's been denying it now
for six months this is a totally new
strategy hard
and we are supporting them 100 percent
everything they
need they get and we are taking good
care we have tremendous supplies and
a great supply chain whether it's
ventilators or
gowns or just about anything they need
so that's a
big difference from inheriting very very
empty
cupboards the median age of those who
succumb to the
china virus is 78 years old roughly half
of all deaths have been individuals in
nursing homes who are long-term
care in one study 90 of those
hospitalized had
underlying medical conditions whether
it's heart or diabetes
but usually it's uh some kind of a
condition it seems that people have that
and if they lose
some problems no question about it young
adults may often have mild or even
no symptoms they won't even know they're
sick
they won't have any idea that they have
a virus are you guys feeling the
push-pull be
between trump trying to say things that
make more sense about this
but being unable to get away get get
away from the empty cupboards and china
virus and this
there's a push pull happening whether
you like the mask or not
they have an impact they'll have an
effect and we need everything we can get
data shows children have the lowest
fatality risk
99.96 of all
virus fatalities have to go to school
so that's uh much much much less than
one percent
for children young people by
understanding these risk
profiles and learning how to treat the
disease
we've been able to greatly reduce
mortality in the united states in fact
we'll
show you a chart and how
well we do compared to the rest of the
world we've have several treatments
already available that significantly
reduce the severity and
duration so this is trump mixing up
deaths per capita with case fatality
rate with infection fatality rate i've
already told you we should be looking at
deaths per capita for what trump is
talking about comparing between
countries
i won't rehash it we've learned best
practices for treatment of the virus
at every stage and have shared these
findings with
medical providers and we've shared them
all over the world
the relationship with other countries
has been very strong we're all working
together this includes ensuring all
hospitals
are aware of the importance of different
approaches to
oxygen treatment including high flow
oxygen the importance of steroid
treatment for those
on ventilators and when you're on a
ventilator
we've learned a tremendous about the use
of the ventilator
and at the beginning people never had an
experience like this
where we needed so many ventilators so
fast and even the use of the vent
letters but the doctors have become
incredibly and nurses and helpers have
become incredibly good at the use of
a ventilator which is actually a very
complicated procedure
and allocating rem disavir to hospitals
based on new
my guess is they told trump stay on
script and the questions may throw him
into an absolute spiral
really started they're using it much
earlier fatalities nationwide
have fallen 75 since mid-april
it's a great number as cases and
fatalities rise in certain hard-hit
states which you're
looking at right now we're surging
personnel
supplies and therapeutics we again have
tremendous amounts of supplies
we are in very good shape and we're
going to move this
rate our case fatality rate has
continued to decline and
is lower than the european union and
almost every remember what matters is
deaths per capita we are 10th highest
this is a deception
check out my clip from yesterday
involved with and suffering from the
china
virus well the world is suffering
very badly but the fact is that many
countries
are suffering very very very badly
and they've been suffering from this
virus for a long time
we've done much better than most and
with the fatality rate at a
lower rate than most it's something that
we can talk about but we're working
again
10th highest deaths per capita in the
world soon to be nine
even know about i get calls all the time
asking for help
especially as it pertains to the
ventilators they need
help with ventilators they have to get
them they're very hard to get
we're making thousands now a month
thousands of ventilators a month
it's been quite amazing we keep doing
the good job and things will get
better and better we'll be putting up
charts behind me
showing different statistics and
different
rates of success and i guess you could
say also
things that we can do better on but
you'll see them
they'll be put up as we go in april the
average age of individuals who tested
positive for the virus was
over 50 years old today the average age
is significantly younger hospital
lengths of
stay are almost half of what they were
in april
so the stays are about about half the
rate of cases requiring hospitalization
let's just switch to a different feed so
we're going to switch also to the
things that we can do better on but
you'll see them
they'll be put up as we go in april
the average age of individuals who
tested positive for the virus was
over 50 years old today the average age
is significantly younger hospital
lengths
of stay are almost half of what they
were in april
so the stays are about half the rate of
cases requiring
hospitalization has been reduced and
mortality among those admitted to the
hospital
is nearly one half of what it was in
april we've learned a lot
we've learned a lot about this disease
how to handle it the doctors have
learned a lot
remember cumulative tests is essentially
meaningless to us right now
and things are happening too like the
rem deserver and
and other elements steroids etc but
these trends could change
without our continued and relentless
focus and that's what we have we have a
relentless focus and it's been that way
from the beginning
but we've learned so much as you know in
recent weeks we've seen a
concerning rise in the cases in many
parts of our
south if you look at south southwest and
west
this growth in cases first began to
appear in mid-june
primarily among 18 to 35 year olds
many of whom were asymptomatic we're
also facing the challenge of a
significant spice in virus cases across
the
rest of the western hemisphere including
mexico mexico's
been hit very very very hard as you know
the president a great gentleman was
here two weeks ago and they have really
been hit hard
because we've achieved a nearly
four-fold increase in testing capacity
in two months we're
successfully identifying more
asymptomatic and
mild cases some cases so mild that you
really don't even treat them
some cases with children
where they don't even know that they're
ill
and i guess they're not very ill because
they recover almost immediately per
capita the u.s
is conducting 50 percent more tests than
europe
and we've conducted nearly three times
as many tests as all of the other
countries in the western hemisphere
combined the over 50 million tests
this allows us to isolate those who are
infected yeah so this is you know
cumulative test doesn't really tell us
much
importantly trump said our capacity has
increased four-fold in the last two
months
what they use this term capacity if you
look at the number of tests done
per day it has an increased four-fold
over the last two months the data is
widely available i'll put it up on the
screen momentarily with all governors
but
right now in particular those governors
we're coordinating
closely with hospitals and governors in
the last three weeks i've
sent senior officials into nine states
to meet with governors and provide
recommendations to the
various leaders of the state including
hospital administrators etc
my administration currently has zero
unfilled
requests for unfulfilled requests for
uh equipment or anything else that they
need from the governors no governor
needs anything
right now and we think we'll have it
that way till
the end because frankly we are stocked
up and ready to go wherever we have to
go we have nearly
7 000 national guard and military
medical personnel in texas california
florida
and arizona that's helping us greatly
want to thank them very much the
military has been fantastic
we're closely monitoring hospital
capacity in these states hospitals are
open
for elective surgeries and other
procedures so hospitals are open for
elective surgeries we want americans to
get the medical treatments they need all
of the governors
we've spoken with say they have enough
bed capacity that's a great thing
our initial shutdown was to prevent the
overflow
of our hospitals and to allow us to meet
the demands caused by this global
pandemic
including the ventilators and a
permanent shutdown was
really never an option in terms of what
we're doing right now
this would be completely unsustainable
produce
debilitating economic fallback and lead
to catastrophic public health
consequences there are consequences to
shutdowns and
we've saved potentially millions of
lives by doing the initial
shutdown but now we're i'm starting to
doubt whether he's going to take
questions he better
large extent nobody's going to maybe
ever fully understand it but we'll end
up
with a cure we'll end up with
therapeutics we'll end up with a vaccine
very soon
all three we're instead asking americans
to use
masks socially distance and employ
vigorous hygiene
wash your hands every chance you get
while sheltering
high risk populations we are imploring
young americans to avoid
packed bars and other crowded indoor
gatherings be safe
and be smart we're surging testing
capacity to identify and isolate cases
this includes a newly approved testing
platform
to nursing homes across the south we're
being very very vigilant with respect to
nursing homes because you know all of
the problems that we've had
with so many people so sadly they were
infected
so that all of the staff and residents
can be routinely tested and isolated
to ensure our elderly are even more
strongly protected than anybody else
that's really the
high-risk people the high-risk
wonderful people once this current surge
in cases declines the same testing
platform will enable people to visit
their loved ones after taking a test
which is a big difference ultimately our
goal
is not merely to manage the pandemic but
to end it we want to get rid of it as
soon as we can
that is why getting a vaccine remains a
top
this attitude would have been worthwhile
in february and march and april and may
stage of clinical trials this month this
was achieved in record time
it used to be years before you were
in a position like we are right now four
other vaccines will enter final trials
in
the following weeks and we're mass
producing all of the top candidates so
that the first approved vaccine will be
available immediately and logistically
we have the military ready to go we have
great people logistic military people a
wonderful general who's
waiting for the vaccine so they can
distribute it in record time that's
what's going to happen so
our military is all set to go oh yeah
that guy we haven't seen for months
vaccine therapeutics whatever it is is
necessary
and defeat the virus once and for all
and i'll take a few questions
if you'd like uh i will say this i want
to thank all of the staff the white
house staff
uh all of the doctors that we've been
working with so closely and
it's just a lot of very positive things
are happening it's a
nasty horrible disease that should have
never
been allowed to escape china but it did
and it
infected the world and the world is
suffering but we're going to get it
taken care of
and we're helping lots of other
countries uh
mr president uh first i just wanted to
get a clarification your press secretary
said today that you
sometimes take more than one test a day
well why is that
and how well i didn't know about more
than one i do ten probably on average a
test every uh
two days three days i don't know if any
time i've taken two tests
he can't think of once he's done two so
republicans and democrats so
they want to see more money for testing
they want to send billions of dollars to
the state so they can do more testing
and you probably saw mick mulvaney the
other day i said that uh
his kids it took him a week to get test
results back he said this is simply
inexcusable given where we are in the
pandemic
do you think we have a problem with
testing in this country right now and
are you in favor of more money for
testing
that i prefer uh-oh
whoa and as we go as an example
there are thousands and thousands
all right we're bailing we're going to
go to a different tonight and tomorrow
on that
and again we're leading the world i
think the second country at 12 million
we're
we're going to be over 50 million tests
second country is india with 12 million
then you have 7 million 6 million and 4
million
i think that uh we are doing tremendous
amount of testing but if
the if the doctors and the professionals
feel
that even though we're at a level that
nobody ever dreamt possible that
they would like to do more i'm okay
where are they your doctor's not with
you here today where's dr
dr burks well dr burks is right outside
yes please
right outside the door number one i just
wanted to know
in november do you want the american
people to judge you
do you want the american people to judge
you on the ballot in november
by how you've handled this pandemic so
far this
among other things i think the american
people will
judge us on this but they'll judge us on
the economy that i created and that
already we're creating we're setting
record job numbers as you know oh not
that again uh i think we're going to
have a very strong
year next year i think we're going to
have a very strong third quarter okay
a very good fourth quarter but i think
next year is going to be a record year
and i think they're going to judge me of
that i think they're going to judge me
on the tax cutting and the regulation
cutting which
nobody's ever done to the extent that
we've been able polls say no one's
judging him on regulation cutting that's
not registering with voters
we got veterans choice nobody thought
that would be possible veterans choices
and obama policy from 2014.
it's called choice where they can go get
a doctor if you have to wait online for
two weeks or five weeks
or two days and frankly uh that's been a
great thing uh
veterans accountability i think they'll
judge me on that no they
they'll judge me in all of the things
we've done i don't think
and i think we can say this we're sure
and it's never been even challenged in
three and a half years the first three
and a half years the first years of a
presidency i don't think any
administration any president has
accomplished so much as we've
accomplished from energy
to health to so many other things and
then this came in
and uh the the plague i call it the
plague the plague came in
terrible thing stopped wasn't stopped it
came in we had to shut things down to
save
potentially millions of lives we did
that and now we've started them up and
uh
i think we've really started it up very
successfully
thank you mr president uh you've been
saying for months the virus would simply
disappear
and now you're saying oh i think it will
get worse before it gets better
if it does keep getting worse if
americans keep dying
are you responsible for that well the
virus will disappear
will disappear i think that i always
like to say as
you know either way when you look at it
the governors are working with me i'm
working with the governor we're working
hand in hand i think we're all
responsible i view it as a team
very good relationships with this is
like the people who say
the world's about the end the world's
about to end it doesn't and they go
listen eventually the sun will
will expand and consume the planet like
eventually i'll be right in a few
billion years well it's not really the
spirit of what you were saying
saved tens of thousands of lives when i
closed the border and nobody wanted to
do it i wanted to do it
we closed the border to china we put on
the ban
we didn't want people coming in from
heavily infected china
fairly shortly thereafter i closed the
borders from
europe coming in from europe those were
tremendous moves we would have
if it's one person it's too much but
we're let's say a hundred and forty
thousand
we could have double triple quadrants
i'm still having a hard time
understanding whether trump saved
thousands hundreds of thousands millions
or billions of lives i can't tell which
it is
uh it's a shame that it happened it
shouldn't have happened
china should have stopped it
thank you president trump um if i could
two question questions
um my first question is we have a very
quick testing platform here at the white
house yes
it's great you get tested you know very
quickly
do you think that it would be easier to
reopen and restart businesses if we
could produce more of those machines
we're trying to do that
great question we're trying very much to
do that so rather than sending your
tests in and you know goes through the
mail one day comes back another day no
matter how
they send them it's a day and a day so
that's two days already wasted
and then if it spends by the time you
get it back it's three or four days if
they do an efficient job we're trying to
get the testing on site
thank you i like it the best and my
follow-up my second question
it's a little bit a different topic but
it's one that a lot of people are
talking about
um just lane maxwell is in prison
and so a lot of people want to know if
she's going to turn in powerful people
and i know you've talked in the past
about prince andrew
and uh you've criticized bill clinton's
behavior i'm wondering
do you feel that she's going to turn in
powerful men how do you see that working
out
i don't know i haven't really been
following it too much i just wish her
well frankly
uh i've met her numerous times over the
years especially since i lived in palm
beach
we know i guess they lived in palm beach
they did but i wish her well
whatever it is uh i don't know the
situation with prince andrew
just don't know not aware of it
on unemployment insurance how much below
600 are you willing to go and you said
that
the palm beach bouncing back strong so
why do we need to even cut it at all
well the economy is getting stronger and
i think we have a chance to have a very
strong economy especially if
some of the things that i just spoke
about work we want to have people
go back and want to go back to work as
opposed to be sort of forced into a
position where they're making more money
than
they expected to make and the employers
are having a hard time getting them back
to wait
i'm confused so that was a
decision that was made i was against
that original decision but they did that
it still worked out well because it gave
people a lifeline a real lifeline now
we're doing it again
uh they're thinking about doing 70 of
the amount the amount would be the same
but doing it in a little bit smaller
initial amounts so that people are going
to want to go back to work as opposed to
making so much money
this makes that sense they really don't
have to but we were very generous with
them
i think that uh it's been a tremendously
successful program the whole thing has
been successful if you look i mean we
have
we're in a pandemic and yet we're
producing tremendous number of
jobs that was something that nobody
thought possible well we recovered
something
thank you very much yesterday you said
that wearing a mask was an act
of patriotism if that is the case why
don't you do it more frequently
well i do actually do it when i need i
mean i carry the mask when i have to go
i went into walter hospital the other
day i have the mask right here i carry
it and i will use it gladly
no problem with it and i've said that
and i say if you
can use the mask when you can use the
mask
if you're close to each other if you're
in a group i would put it on
when i'm in a group if i'm in an
elevator and there are other people with
me including like security people it's
not their fault they have to be in the
elevator i want to protect them also
i put on a mask wow what a presidential
i will have i have no problem with the
masks
i view it this way anything that
potentially can help
and that certainly can potentially help
is a good thing i have no problem i
carry it
i wear it you saw me wearing it a number
of times and i'll continue please
go ahead please are you sending mixed
messages yesterday you tweeted out an
image wearing a mask
and then last evening we saw you not
wearing a mask at your hotel
well i don't know uh the hotel i was
pretty far away from people but
i would say this uh i've explained it i
think very
well if you're close together i would
put on the
mask and if you're not i would say that
if you're
for instance i'll see like here you've
been all tested i've been tested
oftentimes i'll be with people that are
fully tested i've been tested
in theory you don't need the mask i'm
getting used to the mask and the reason
is
think about patriotism maybe it is it
helps
it helps now we have experts that have
said in the recent past that
masks aren't necessarily going to work
you know that here we go
but now they've changed their mind if
they change their mind that's good
enough for me so i wear it when
appropriate please
thank you sir um a lot of americans
though may be surprised at your
change of tone over all of this some
more also around
realistic time someone look at it that
way the sudden embrace of masks
social distancing the uh well i've
always agreed with that i mean i've
never fought
either one but certainly social
distancing i wanna
it's it's that's common sense six feet
to me is common sense i'd like to say
maybe make it a little bit further
the idea that um things will get worse
perhaps before they get better here
and there perhaps the realization that
this resurgence
if you will is for real when you used to
talk about it in terms of little fires
being put
out here and there we have that
responsibility no we have embers and
fires and we have big fires and
we've got unfortunately now florida is
uh in a little tough
uh or in a big tough position you have a
great governor there you have a great
governor in texas you have
people that are very very skilled people
and i think they're going to handle it
very well
their hospital capacities are holding up
but texas is a big state and it's very
well run and so is florida and
i think they'll do a very good job
changing your tone though sir
ask you about the issue of vaccines
which you already mentioned um yesterday
a study by
a chinese company showed some promising
results for its coronavirus vaccine
candidate
if china were first in developing the
vaccine or even if it weren't
would the administration be willing to
work with china to bring a successful
chinese vaccine to the u.s
yeah we're willing to work with anybody
that's going to get us a good result
we're very close to the vaccine i think
we're going to have some very good
uh results we're already in testing
nobody thought that would be possible
under the old system would be a year to
two years before you could even think
about
using the word testing so i think we've
had a lot of
energy and the reason we're testing
they've had good results so now we have
to see in the testing also for safety
because i have to make sure it's safe
and i think you're going to see
something over the next fairly short
period of time maybe very short period
of time having to do with therapeutics
and vaccines
that are very good so we'll be doing
these quite often
we're going to keep you abreast of this
and we'll also talk about some of the
other topics like our economy
doing well the stock market had another
good day i think they have a good day
because they see
a lot of positive things happening on
this front too thank you very much thank
you
thank you so it is a new donald trump
clearly realizing
that everything he has done for six
months has been a failure and he needs
to do
something new uh a conciliatory trump a
trump that
is um i don't even know what to call it
uh
sort of accepting reality to some degree
i guess we would say
uh i don't know if it's too little too
late you know there's still a lot you
can sense the bs in there the
florida's well run ron desantis is a
complete lunatic
um you know we're putting out embers
it's like no we we are now
we're arguably not even at the peak we
are peaking but the next peak may be
even very much higher so this is merely
a strategy
to try to win some votes back because he
sees according to rasmussen
a right-wing pollster he's losing by
three
to biden according to multiple other
polls he's losing by between 10 and 15.
so
will this last can trump be this more
sort of sensible trump for any
significant period of time
i really don't know i i don't know uh as
you saw starting to go
into his his typical antics there when
asked some of those tougher
questions it's going to be a matter of
uh
of of wait and see i don't know what to
expect but we will see if there is
another one of these tomorrow
okay i'm gonna go because i still have
my third stream of the day coming up
later it'll be on twitch
it'll be with alexandra botes and it
will be my continued training for the
upcoming pog champs ii chess tournament
i agree i get that that's not serious
stuff we've got a lot of very serious
things
but we're trying to balance and do some
things that are a little bit less
serious so i will see all of you a
little bit later at twitch.tv
david pakman
you